robbie's coming off an excellent start
last time out yeah we saw robbie down in
miami fourning's pitched only one hit
uh five k's no walks i think that's the
big thing that has got him this next
start no walks he throws strikes
hopefully today we can see maybe five
five in the third and now harper's the
batter and he has had great success
head-to-head with robbie erlin
he had pretty good numbers against them
that one has hit well deep to right
center field it is gone
more than halfway up the seats in right
center field bryce harper with a seventh
home run of the year and again the
phillies jump out to the early lead it
is two nothing here in the top of the
first
first pitch fastball hunting was bryce
harper goes up top over everything
you mentioned the numbers six or eight
coming into tonight's ball game against
erlang
this ball is
crushed
to right field
my goodness
you talking about a quick bat to go
along with power
109.6 off the bat
zach wheeler stayed in the division went
from the mets to the phillies with a big
contract he's off to a great start
ground ball to the left side and nice
play at third segura long throw and he
got him by a quarter step
sagura took away a hit with a great
diving play and there's the first out
wow well not just a play but to be able
to get up as fast he did throw a strike
over to first
dansby's got good speed
you can see him up knew he had to get
rid of it
some kind of play for out number one
go to pitch
swinging to miss beautiful pitch second
strikeout for wheeler
swinging a miss and the side is retired
two strikeouts in the inning three
overall
freeze hoskins reached on the error and
now aj minter is on the face uh bryce
harper
runner goes hoskins got a heck of a jump
reese hoskins with a stolen base
outside off the glove of flowers and
reece goes to third
jt real muto will get a chance now that
ball's pulled past the diving reilly
into left field it'll bring home reese
hoskins the philly scored unearned run
of the fifth inning the phillies had a
run it's three nothing on the smash by
jt rimuto
zach wheeler has scattered three hits
over the first five innings he'll go to
work against the top of the order
swag gonna miss strikeout number six for
wheeler let's talk about total control
tonight love the curveball tonight it's
just nasty he throws the get me over o
curveball we've seen him do that a
couple times tonight then he goes for
the the punch in the gut curve ball
filthy
balls hit sharply toward third segura
very comfortably throws across the
diamond
the side is retired six scoreless
innings for zach wheeler he has six
strikeouts he has scattered three hits
and now mccutchen
that ball is drilled down to left field
ozuna's going back toward the wall he
jumps and it's gone
a home run for andrew mccutchen his
second of the year
and it's four-nothing phillies
coach gets a fastball up and in and he's
missed a couple of those today and you
can see the frustration on it
and then he gets it
good pitch
better swing bushes
and a swing and a miss adams swung at
the breaking ball three times and is
retired that's seven strikeouts
for zach wheeler who's the first
opposing starter
to enter the seventh inning against the
braves with a shutout this year he's had
a plus stuff from the opening bell
train's coming down a little harder now
as this one's hit high in the air deep
toward left center field quinn on the
run still going back and through the
rain drops austin reilly has hit a
two-run homer so the braves are back in
the game partner it's now four to two
i'm guessing as a hitter he's looking
fast he got really the first bad
curveball zach wheeler's throwing
tonight uh big old looper and austin so
strong that's what just get the bat head
there
back to the box and wheeler's got it and
he'll go halfway to first flip under
hand side is retired well the braves get
two on the home run by riley seven solid
innings from zach wheeler whose night is
most likely done phil's lead it four to
two as we go to the eighth
and it is going to be hector naris who
has blown his last three save
opportunities
hot shot of base in right field here
comes dansby around third he's gonna
score freddie freeman is two third and
the braves are down a run and now the
phillies have brought in brandon workman
line drive toward left that ball's going
to get down that ball is going to tie
the game here comes ozuna to third
they're going to wave him he's around
third here comes the relay
away from rio and the braves take the
lead adam's on his way to third he's
safe
the first pitch workman throws as a
philly reliever and the braves touch him
for a couple of runs and take a 5-4 lead
the base is loaded and harper already
with a two-run homer heavy 0-1
that one's out toward left field it's
right at the left fielder ozuna tagging
from third heading for home is walker
the throw to the plate on one hop he's
safe at home he got his hand in
that was a heck of a throw too and the
phillies have tied it up at five
i think brian sniffer's already said
take a look at it i'm sorry that's pache
in left field and we talked about his
arm and how strong it was
looks like walker got his hand in there
i can't believe it was that close
and he is safe it's a 5-5 game here in
the top of the ninth inning
and the bases are loaded now for adam
duvall
line drive braves winning adam duvall
drives home dansby swanson and the
braves have won the game they've won
this series and they moved to 16 and 11
on the year what a furious final three
inning comeback